le mardi c'est le genre de la chronique
environnement bonsoir julie et danseurs
anthony puisqu'on va parler de sport
aussi on parle écologie et sports tennis
tout à fait on va commencer par
l'opération sportive et écologique balle
jaune avec stéphane fugace directeur de
la ligue des yvelines de tennis et
véronique moreau vice présidente en
charge des actions sociales et
solidaires alors tout simplement en quoi
consiste cette opération alors
l'opération balle jaune est une
opération qui consiste à collecter
auprès de tous les clubs des yvelines
les balles jaunes usagers afin de leur
faire faire une nouvelle vie une seconde
vie c'est à dire de les recycler pour
refaire des surfaces sportives adaptées
à la rééducation motrice ou à des aires
de jeux ou est également à des
structures comme des instituts médico
éducatifs qui ont besoin de structures
pouvant armes amortir les chocs pour
pouvoir développer différentes activités
de rééducation donc ont précisé des sols
spécialisés non pas pour le grand public
tout à fait ce sont des sols spécialité
d'accord donc 27 league sur 36 en france
participent à cette cinquième édition
dont la vôtre stéphane feugas depuis
quand la liste des yvelines de tennis y
participent
alors institutionnellement ça avait été
acté en 2009
et concrètement la collecte des balles a
démarré en 2010 36 mille balles
collectées en 2010 52 milles en 2011 et
2012 2013 56000 on voit qu'il ya une
vraie évolution avec les clubs
participent depuis en plus combien en
totale sur les yvelines alors sur les
167 club ou affiliés aujourd'hui c'est
environ entre 100 et 120 clubs et on va
dire le fait que les clubs participent
plus c'est le fait qu'il y ait plus de
communication et tous les pratiquants et
dirigeants sont sensibilisés mais quand
vous dites les clubs participent plus ce
sont les joueurs justement qui font
attention à leur bal qui les ramassent
les clubs d attention votre cotisation
va coûter plus cher si voire même par au
bal non
en avoir c'est à dire qu'effectivement
c'est chez les pratiquants sensibilisés
par les adhérents et les enseignants qui
collectent leur bal en club et c'est la
collecte qui se passe de novembre à fin
mars et aujourd'hui c'était la collecte
en ligue tour de france coved tenir
toutes les digues
alors vous faites du tennis désole un
survival d'ailleurs pour dit on c'est
vous le savez bien sûr l'ancien balles
de tennis bravo si tu fais dans mon club
il existe ce traditionnel panier où on
insère évidemment les balles usagées qui
ont qui ont fait leur première vie un
bon point on essaye à traiter l'info
d'histoire alors vers une féraud quel
est le message en fait à véhiculer est
ce que c'est le recyclage des balles
c'est ça je pense que c'est une
opération gagnante gagnante c'est à dire
que pour tous les pratiquants
le fait d'avoir des balles usagées qui
traînent dont on sait pas quoi faire
comment s'en débarrasser et bien il ya
un carton spécifique dans tous les clubs
participants il est très facile de
déposer ses balles et que la presse est
une action tout simplement
environnementale économique et sociale
donc je pense que c'est vraiment du
gagnant gagnant pour tout et les
participants à cette action
mais alors vous parlez de balles usagées
quand est-ce qu'on peut on peut décider
qu'une balle et est finie elle ne peut
plus servir pour jouer en match
un art ça c'est un éternel débat l'agent
de service et andeva et tout dépend du
joueur c'est à dire que entre un joueur
compétiteur qu'il y faisait énormément
et une balle de mini tennis pour un
clone de cinq ans l'as wihr boulistes et
où est ce que vous êtes plutôt entre les
deux voilà donc forcément la durée de
vie d'une balle peut aller de
un match de tennis à quelques semaines
dans les écoles de tennis par rapport à
l'utilisation qu'on peut en faire
mais elle devenait quoi ces balles avant
d'être recyclées elles étaient jetés
dans les déchetteries je dirais dans les
poubelles dans le cycle classique et
c'est vrai que c'est dommage puisque
tout ce qui est matière caoutchouc à une
deuxième vie potentielle et donc c'est
très
utile pour tout le monde est très
économique est encore une fois tout le
monde doit penser à sa consommation que
ce soit au niveau des activités
professionnelles mais aussi au niveau
des associations de savoir que la
pratique sportive puisque tel est le cas
peut engendrer aussi des déchets et à ce
moment-là rentrer dans un cycle de
recyclage comme tout à chacun à y penser
un petit chiffre plutôt gros 14 millions
de balles sont vendus chaque année en
france
donc jusque là elle était traitée dans
le circuit traditionnel comme un produit
de consommation c'est-à-dire incinérés
donc là on a une nouvelle manière de
traiter ces déchets on va revenir sur
les cinq étapes clés de l'opération
balle jaune
donc là on a eu la collecte dans les
différents clubs ensuite aujourd'hui
même on a vu que des cartes ont été
chargées dans le camion d'un oui dans le
camion de la coved
donc c'est le pardon la société
spécialisée dans le traitement et la
valorisation des déchets combien vous
avez chargés de cartons aujourd'hui tous
les détenus voilà c'était pour les
images on a fait appel à pas deux
présidents de clubs qui sont venus
donner un coup de main ça représente les
50 6 me bats ça représente 175 carton de
320 balle dans une opération logistique
très pensée très rationaliser cette
manière les cartes ont une certaine
taille telle manière à rentrer dans le
camion et suite demain socan on va aller
dans un autre site notre ligue et il va
faire un d'affaires le taux de cilic
pour remplir complètement le cas de nous
pour éviter les kilomètres et pression
bien il faut de deux balles pour faire
un tapis en exemple alors on dire
environ 50 mille balles petites
variations c'est selon l'épaisseur que
vous n'avez eu le tapis sportifs il peut
faire un centimètre 5 à 2 cm d'épaisseur
si vous nous suivez en direct vous venez
me rejoindre on parle de balles de
tennis
avant le langage n'a pas changé sur tv
films tram pour l'instant de bâle ii
donc l'étape numéro 3 parce que je suis
le fils on a donc le broyage des balles
qui va être effectué donc un pas celle
dans l'oise
oui tout à fait par la société coved et
donc ses balles vente est broyé on va en
séparer la feutrine de la matière
caoutchouc est d'accord la matière qu
cloud est fragmentée en fait en
granulats et la suite c'est que ce
granulats va être mélangés à de la
résine de polyuréthane qui va être cool
et sur un sol préparer à lavance pour
faire ce revêtement sportif est donc la
cinquième étape c'est le parrainage de
structures locales
la liste des yvelines a justement par et
nunes un établissement de poissy en 2011
pouvez nous en dire deux mots ce moment
c'est un peu la vocation d'ailleurs de
l'opération le recyclage mais pour le
but pour peut impliquer tous les
dirigeants c'est quelque part il ya une
réalisation d'un seul sportif donc en
2000 on a eu la chance de pouvoir
réaliser ce à la maison de poissy on
voit les la maison d'accueil spécialisé
donc pour handicap l'os et ses quarante
jeunes adultes polyhandicapés et donc la
particularité c'était sur une terrasse
qui n'avait pas tellement d'usagé et
l'établissement d'un demandez-donc 162
mètres carrés qui ont été réalisés
aujourd'hui tous les pensionnaires
peuvent utiliser la petite rééducation
sur des exercices adaptés au handicap et
pour l'occasion d'oublier
encore une belle inauguration avec les
ministres dans l'un des sports à
l'époque et et pour 2013 est ce qu'une
structure locale va accueillir un projet
parfait alors c'est l'opportunité on a
dit de lancer un appel à projet puisque
suite à l'opération d'aujourd'hui nous
enverrons un mail demain en 70
structures établissements spécialisés
dans des cas pour justement savoir les
établissements qui seraient candidats
pour réaliser sachant que de la ligue
finance via ses partenaires conseil
général d'aider cfc fédération française
de tennis
la révélation du sol sportif c'est à
dire à partir de granulats
tout ce qu'on demande c'est que
l'établissement finances la préparation
du sol donc appel à projet officiel très
bien qu'une entente rebelles avec nous
on ça vraiment heureux tous les
pratiquants et dirigeants sont très
heureux de voir la finalité d'un sol
sportif pour des handicapés et dernière
question combien ça coûte cette
opération à la ligue de tennis des
yvelines sur ce qui a été fait la maison
de marie aux sanglots c'était un budget
de 19 mille euros donc avec les
partenariats à les sapins sa patrie on
va dire c'est moi le l'idée c'est de
rendre service et dans une opération de
développement durable à vocation sociale
julien petit rappel des chiffres tout à
fait donc c'est la cinquième édition de
l'opération balle jaune en 2013
en pot total depuis 2009 presque 3
millions de balles ont été recueillis
pour offrir 19 tapis à des organismes
locaux dont six à paris et l'île de
france et cette année on espère enfin la
ligue 2 enfin la fédération française de
tennis même espère recueillir 1 25
millions de balles pour réaliser trois
mille mètres carrés de sol spécifique
c'est l'équivalent de onze courts
horaires de recul si je ne me trompe pas
c'est précis merci à vous de mercialys a
invité est arrivée cette page
d'environnement à présent un coup d'oeil
à l'agenda
oui alors on est en pleine semaine du
développement durable qui débute
aujourd'hui officiellement je vous
propose trois rendez vous l'exposition
l'habitat de tes rêves qui présente des
oeuvres réalisées dans le cadre scolaire
par des jeunes saint quentinois
notamment pour réfléchir sur les éco
matériaux les étapes de construction
prenant en compte l'environnement ou
encore les économies d'énergie à
découvrir jusqu'au 27 avril
maison de l'environnement de magny les
hameaux toujours sur la thématique de
l'habitat l'atelier ma maison est
construite par l' agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat de saint quentin
en yvelines propose de découvrir comment
utiliser intelligemment les ressources
naturelles de notre région
c'est samedi 6 avril à la maison de
l'environnement de magny les hameaux et
enfin un jeu de l'oie géant est animé
par le musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines pour évoquer avec
les enfants dès 8 ans les enjeux de la
ville durable ça se passe demain
mercredi 3 avril à la maison de
l'environnement de magny les hameaux
merci je lis pour ce point environnement
va faire à présent à point football on
va changer de sujet si vous me suivez en
direct plus que quelques heures avant le
coup d'envoi de la rencontre à ne pas
manquer ce soir